Nicola Sturgeon Scotland's First
Minister has demanded immediate
guarantees about the residency rights of
people from other EU countries currently
living in Scotland the First Minister
has written to David Cameron the Prime
Minister and the five conservative
leadership candidates ahead of a summit
with European diplomats in Edinburgh on
Tuesday while I'm joined now by her
predecessor Alex Salmond who's now of
course the SNP s Foreign Affairs
spokesman he's in Aberdeen sure and a
very good morning to you mister Salmond
now this son demand for guarantees for
EU nationals residing in Scotland II
even if those guarantees were given by
the Prime Minister and indeed all the
five leadership hopefuls some presumably
they're not worth much because
negotiations need to take place with the
European Union about all those kind of
things in the exit procedure no they
would be worth something of course they
would dammit because whether the rights
of residency are guaranteed under
European law or under a decision of the
UK government they would still be
guaranteed and therefore Nicola Sturgeon
who incidentally has been playing a an
absolute blinder throughout this
throughout this process probably the
only political leader of which that
could be said it's absolutely right it's
a demand that guarantee now instead of
people facing the uncertainty and also
just as I know people both in Scotland
of England that the feeling of lack of
welcome and therefore to have a
political leader light necklace touch
and to layer on the way in the sea these
people should be guaranteed they're
hardworking people contributing
massively to this country the right
should be guaranteed now is exactly the
right move to make but there are those
saying AHA this is a clever ploy and you
know the the guarantee some might not be
coming from Westminster and that the
best way of making sure that guarantees
a Copperbottom is that the sturgeon
could answer her own question as leader
of an independent Scotland then she can
unequivocally say that to EU Nationals
can I tell you something Dermot
this whole crisis about the UK's
relationship with the European Union
Scotland's relationship with Europe
this is God loyal way beyond clever
ploys there's been a seismic movement of
opinion in Scotland which
says that one way or another Scotland's
position in Europe must be consolidated
and garbin teed and Nicola Sturgeon is
caring not just the SNP opinion behind
her but abroad
spread a political opinion in Scotland
this is way way beyond political ploys
this is about national leadership which
Nicola Sturgeon is providing indeed I
mean but tell me in your gut mr. Sammon
do you feel another independence
referendum coming given the the mess
there seems to be in Westminster at the
moment the leadership vacuum yes and my
guts I do but Nikolas dodging is
perfectly right to make her negotiating
priority to examine every possible way
to consolidate Cotton's position as a
European nation and then as that unfolds
then decisions will have to be made but
she's doing exactly the right thing and
I give her my unconditional support on
that and and how in how much detail have
you examined as far as spokesmen of
course some some kind of deal that while
all the negotiations are going on while
the brexit processes is taking place
that Scotland even if it has not left
the United Kingdom remains within the
European Union people talking about some
kind of parallels with with Denmark and
its membership for instance yeah that's
the reverse Greenland let's call it that
damn it's under half to go 48 and the
argument is that the Kingdom of Denmark
includes both the Faroe Islands and
Greenland but denmark continues in the
European Union but the Greenland and
indeed the Faroe Islands are out with EU
competence that's the example that that
people cite but that should be explored
it should be examined to see if people
are prepared to to come to some sort of
agreement on that but you know that's
only one of a number of options I don't
actually if it's the most promising
option myself but nonetheless Nicola
Sturgeon is quite right to explore all
options and and that is exciting what
should be done this now I mean she is
the only leader who's participating in
negotiation she's the only one with a
plan which is quite remarkable given
that among the people who should have a
plan are those two who wanted brexit in
the first place what is
most promising option in your view mr.
Sammon well necklace dodging is taking
things in improper order and that is to
establish how Scotland's position within
the European context can be protected
that's what people in Scotland voted for
by 62% to 38% every single area of
Scotland she also has a mandate from
Mays elections but it was made quite
clear that under these circumstances if
indeed Scotland were to be threatened
with being dragged out of Europe against
the will of the Scottish people then the
Scottish Parliament would be entitled to
hold another independence referendum she
has a perfect mandate for these
situations which are memorizing but
she's absolutely right to take forward
that express well with the Scottish
people to the main part of the European
framework now I want to ask you whether
you agree with somewhat Tony Blair the
former prime minister was saying to me
on this program an hour ago I know
there's an awful lot you disagree with
him about but let's start perhaps with
this when it comes to the negotiations
with the European Union that said the UK
should keep its options open and no
hurry presumably then to to trigger
article 50 of the Lisbon Treaty well I'm
not certain that the European cause
which is under such difficulty at the
present moment is going to be greatly
aided by Tony Blair's assistance like
you can't undo what has been done there
has been a referendum in the UK and
English politicians will follow the
mandate they've been given from the
people just as necklace dodgem is
following the mandate she's been given
from the Scottish people you could
conjecture that the only way you could
get into a different situation if there
was another general election and then
that general election a party or parties
were elected with a different mandate
from the people then you'd be in
different circumstances but I'm not safe
than that 20 Blair's hence and
suggestions you might undo a referendum
it's just taken place it's going to be
an enormous asset to the European cause
at the present moment just on that mr.
Sammon so if we got a majority of
parties within a parliament after a
general election that were unequivocally
wanting to remain members of the
European Union the SNP presumably
amongst them you're saying you might
band together to overturn the referendum
results well can I just point out and
that tame skill that you're putting
forward unless there was a snap general
election which seems to be getting less
likely given the mood music within the
Conservative Party indeed that's the one
thing that are united on not to have a a
general election that I think there'll
be other constitutional developments
which shall all have taken these events
and Scotland let me ask you about a
potential criminal developments in the
you know we mentioned Tony Blair there
the Chilkoot inquiry finally reporting
on Wednesday after six years and some um
you've said in the past that you believe
there may be grounds to investigate mr.
Blair's role in particular that the deal
he did or didn't do with george w bush
to join in the invasion of iraq yeah i
mean two things about Blair's interview
mean firstly remarkably coy he's not
going to talk to you until weddings they
mean that didn't talk stop him talking
to CNN last october if when he
apologized for other people's action the
famous non-apology apology or for that
matter a few weeks ago to your rival
program on a sunday morning but he was
already preparing his defenses remember
tony blair has seen the Chilkoot report
the passages relating to him and has
seen it for months he's had months to
prepare with his legal advisers these PR
advisers the families of the hundred and
seventy nine British dead are going to
get three hours of notice this coming
Wednesday and that disparity of
preparation and information is one of
the the many disgraces in the political
system that we have the other thing
about Tony Blair's interview was he
seemed puzzled as to why Jeremy Corbyn
thinks he's a war criminal why people
don't like him the reason as 179 British
war dead 150,000 immediate dead from the
Iraq conflict in the Middle East in
flames the world face when existential
crisis on terrorism these are just some
of the reasons perhaps issue understand
why people don't hold them in the
highest regard
mr. summit have you had conversations
with Jeremy Corbyn about that very
shuh about practically trying to get
Tony Blair to to answer some of those
charges you're making no I haven't but
not in recent time not since these
become leader of the Labour Party for
example or conversations in the past but
I've had very recent conversations with
a number of Labour members of parliament
and they you know we are waiting to see
choked up producing the evidence which
we believe is there which were a low
action to be taken now that action is
going to be difficult because the the
most obvious crime of which twenty beer
could be charged is a war of aggression
and the International Criminal Court
doesn't as yet have jurisdiction over
that ironically that would happen until
next January and the domestic courts at
least in England have chosen not to
pursue crimes which are international
that's been a the general rule of the
domestic courts in England incidentally
that's not been tested in Scotland
Dermot and then the third option of
which many MPs are interested and
subject to the findings of the Chilkoot
report and that's which parliamentary
methods could be used to hold someone if
the evidence is there to proper account
but one way or another
there are many MPs and this is not a
party political thing this is across the
political parties who are absolutely
determined the account has to be held to
that you cannot have a situation where
this country blunders into an illegal
war of the appalling consequences at the
end of the day there isn't a reckoning
there has to be a judicial or political
reckoning for that ok mr. Sammon thank
you very much indeed Alex Salmond there
the espy's Foreign Affairs spokesman